au premier coup d'oeil ces sacs à pain
aurait un d'extraordinaire mais on y
trouve des numéros d'urgence et un
violent tôt m une initiative saluée
c'est très bien de mettre des de
diffuser des messages qui sont
importants pour tout le monde vous faire
prendre conscience à tout le monde que
c'est important il faut les aider les
femmes et qui sont violentes et je pense
que c'est bien de tirer l'attention de
des personnes sur ce qui se passe autour
de nous des sacs à pain pensé par la
mairie de vaines les deux boulangeries
de la commune ont été livrés ce mardi
1er juin
je vais essayer de pas les mettra
toujours aux mêmes
ça sert à rien je pense qu'il faut
partager un peu plus ma copine
travaillant là dedans
elle m'a un peu sensibilisés à ça et ben
moi j'ai des gens que je connais qui
n'ont subi et tout le monde perd
quelqu'un qui connaît qui a subi sa est
un moment pour que ça s'arrête
un moyen d'entrer d'informer au sein
même des foyers pour la commune de 7500
habitants les milliers de sacs à pain
que nous avons fait imprimer on
permettent de diffuser toutes ces
informations
et on espère qu effectivement si dans
une famille on a ses problèmes
intrafamiliaux qu'ils puissent prendre
appui sur ces sacs à main pour se
libérer la parole dix mille sacs à pain
ont été remis ils viennent compléter les
actions d'associations et de gendarmerie
en 2019 près de 200 femmes hommes et
enfants sont morts de violences
intrafamiliales